what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
what's going on guys this is Rob and a
few weeks ago we're really about a week
and a half ago something like that
Warner Brothers flew myself in in comics
Torian and and Dan T editor and like uh
J roar and uncaged games and and caboose
know all these guys flew us all out to
Los Angeles and we got to check out the
DC Lego super villains game which is
coming out October 16th and it was
pretty awesome actually
he was really really enjoyable uh the
character selection screen is what
you're looking at right now which was
actually pretty fun to go through
there's a lot of options here there's a
lot of choices a lot of things that you
can do and tinker around and have a
great time certainly a game that I'm
looking forward to seeing but I figured
I go ahead and let you guys know that it
was an awesome experience I'm sure you
guys are probably gonna buy it anyway
because you know like it's a it's a Lego
game and those games are always fun but
uh yeah be on the lookout October 16th
that's when the game drops make sure you
guys go and buy it
okay so we're getting into infinity Wars
oh really infinity wars part two this is
basically coming off the heels of like
Gamora capturing the Infinity stones
which is kind of weird the idea that
Gamora was basically a character called
Requiem who killed Thanos honestly I
felt like it was way too early for a
reveal I'm not really sure why
Geri Dugan decided to drop the reveal so
fast but uh no maybe there's other crazy
stuff in store the only thing I can
surmise here is that to vengers for is
gonna end with Gamora taking out Thanos
and so it was more like an editorial
mandate because we know like like
Marvel's kind of adjusting the comics to
copy the the Marvel Cinematic Universe
and so it's kind of interesting but the
fact remains here that what this does is
kind of pick up with the past a little
bit and it really kind of gives us like
this continual journey with regards to
chemours care to remember
she's part of a race called the Xin well
beerus and her people were wiped out by
another group i think it was the oh god
what was it it starts with a be the
badoon I gave a rough top my head anyway
it's when she was an adult she went back
and wiped out the people who wiped out
her people so when she was younger of
course Thanos taking her under his wing
really taught her to be pretty hardcore
I mean basically turn you'll help to
turn her into like one of the world and
one of the universe's most you know
four-digit assassins really the most
dangerous woman in the universe but one
of the things that Thanos talks about
here and this is kind of interesting one
of the things he talks about here is the
idea that basically everything ends you
know that everything will die at some
point or another and he really follows
this ideology that like only the
strongest life and only the strongest
live survive no this is kind of
uncharacteristic of Thanos his character
and the reason why I say that is right
now in Marvel Comics in the present day
Thanos is kind of abandoned the idea of
mistress death right he walked away from
that and said she's basically a lost
cause and so you didn't want to have
anything to do it but then like when you
go back and you look at that hose in the
past he was very much enamored with
mistress death and so it wouldn't really
make a whole lot of sense for him to
adopt this mentality that like only the
strong deserve to survive because the
governing factor of Thanos and
everything he did was attaining the
affections of mistress death and so it
would make more sense here if he said
well I I killed him to please mistress
death you know because death wants death
like you know the the sacrifice of life
or life is meaningless because of course
he's a nihilist or something along those
lines but he doesn't really say that he
just kind of hints to like kind of an
extreme social Darwinist perspective
that only the strong deserve to survive
and it's kind of a funny thing because
Gamora responds by saying well I mean if
that's true then the time will come when
you will die I mean you told me as much
but like somebody will kill you and
Thanos recognizes it and says yes that's
the nature of things the universe is
grooming someone to take me out so again
it's not really care
turistic of tano's for us to hear him
talk that way and that's why it's so
treated so intriguing because there's
obviously a lot of influence here coming
for the Marvel Cinematic Universe is
being copied over into the comics or I
guess the comics copying over into the
Marvel Cinematic Universe and so again
you know picking up with Gamora killing
Thanos what we also find out here is it
wasn't so clear-cut know where she well
no pun intended but where she she cut
off his head that Thanos actually began
speaking to her telepathically now this
is ambiguous here and we don't really
know exactly how this falls with Thanos
sort of walking away from mistress death
and really kind of leaving her behind ah
Thanos going his own way Oh what this
basically meant was it seems like Thanos
may have been barred from the realm of
mystery stuff and if that's true his
Kapoor I guess is essence may continue
to live on but historically speaking in
Marvel Comics when someone like like
take for example Deadpool is barred from
from the realm of the Dead or even when
it comes to comes with a nose himself
who was banned from the realm of
mistress death
there's simply just immortal they just
can't die their spiritual essence
doesn't live on their physical body just
can't be destroyed it's impossible to
kill them because there's nowhere for
them to go and so it's kind of crazy
here because of course you know Gamora
responds by wiping out the rest of the
Chitauri army and that really kind of
brings them to it brings them to a close
and so it switches back over to the
really where the last story left off
when Gamora killed star-lord when she
killed Peter quill now of course if you
want to want to know what was going on
there check out the video down in the
description and of course you know we
also have the infinity war playlist and
so on but where she goes to impale him
what we end up having is Doctor Strange
invoking the time stone and stopping
time now this is kind of an intriguing
move because of course this is obviously
again you know the Marvel Cinematic
Universe being rolled in and Doctor
Strange basically saves Peter quill and
of course he doesn't heal him that
doesn't happen right off the bat I said
he just basically kind of saves him and
then from there you know he actually
goes to the process of healing em you
know as soon as all that's done but it's
intriguing here because not everyone
knows how to react and so what you end
up having Doctor Strange basically doing
is taking like taking Turk Turk Turk
Barrett and then whisking him off to
another to another dimension
now what Doctor Strange is doing here is
basically pitching a kind of a middle
ground and the reason why is remember
Turk got the mind stone and what it
allowed him to do was read the minds of
like stockbrokers and things like that
and start investing his money in a way
that turned him until I can a man who
was worth you know mountains and
mountains of money worth an absolute
fortune and so dr. strange response is
we have to get the Infinity stones off
the planet Earth if we have them all in
a singular location it'll be that much
easier for Gamora to access
so we have to disperse them all across
the cosmos and turn it into a hunt that
would take her thousands of years to
finally figure out but remember this is
one of the things that that that I don't
know if Jerry Dugan seems to forget or
if you just do it in the story and dr.
strange forgot but remember the Infinity
stones want to be brought together we
know that from Brian Michael Bendis is
Illuminati run we know it from Johnathan
Hickman's Avengers and New Avengers run
if you have one stone it'll lead you to
all the others because they want to be
reunited remember they all hail from a
singular being this constantly trying to
reform itself and where we would think
that Gomorrah would still be in a
basically a lost ball on high weeds
trying to track these stones down
remember she has the power sown in power
stone in her sword so she already has a
kind of homing beacon for the rest of
the Infinity stones wherever they happen
to be the smartest decision by dr.
strange would be to scatter that
scattered them across different
dimensions to take them to like
different dimensions now that may very
well have been a plan and it seems like
the most likely thing at least given dr.
Strange's power because in that case
Gamora would never be able to find them
but neither would anybody else it would
literally be everyone relying on Stephen
strange to make the decision to reform
the gems and then presumably reformed
the Infinity Gauntlet if the crisis was
bad enough but again it's it's pretty
cool here you know it's pretty
intriguing because in the middle of this
fight that's continually going on
between the guardians of the galaxy and
and you know this sort of hodgepodge of
our superheroes and the various villains
who were there we end up having like
Iron Man who arrives on the scene now
again this is coming down with a big
guns this is when the big guys are
stepping in and saying look this has
gone on long enough we're in this kind
of a situation we've basically been
dealing with like small fries for the
most part I mean you got dr. strange
who's not really a small fry but for the
most part it's it's really you know
small fries through everything else and
this of course leads into like though
we're showing up to meet with Peter
quill to meet with uh meet with
star-lord Carol Danvers makes her
arrival as well this is kind of a cool
thing and I like how Jerry Dugan does
this is it doesn't really pull any
punches with a character of Gamora and
the reason why is because she's
extremely capable I mean she got super
Street superhuman strength speed and
durability and all those different
things and while she's not necessarily a
pound for pound match for Carol Danvers
or at least it doesn't really seem like
she would be do be really kind of like
amps her powers up a little bit and
actually says yes she is now of course
this also comes my way of her wielding
the power stone and that gives her kind
of a boost to the energy that she had
before remember the power stone is
basically like raw power given form so
energy projections superhuman strength
anything that involves a power based
element it would allow a person to
amplify their abilities multiple times
over whatdo gun also seems to do is sort
of limit it
you know limited in scope because the
Infinity stones are not finite stones
the Infinity stones are literally
infinite and so wielding the power stone
gives you infinite power punching Carol
Danvers knocking her unconscious
it seems pretty straight for this of
course leads to Thor throwing his hammer
Captain America throwing his shield and
everyone's looking to try to face off
against Gamora and take her out this is
actually a genius moment here it's one
of the one of the one of the coolest
moments of the story and Jerry Dugan
really kind of pulls a rabbit out of his
hat here the way this goes down is you
end up having Carol Danvers grabbing
Gamora and whisking her into space now
Carol Danvers depending on the story
depending on the circumstance she can
tap into her binary powers occasionally
and it'll allow her to like breathe in
space and different things like that
when she flies Gamora up into the air it
resumed ibly knocks you out because the
oxygen is so thin and the result is that
she basically brings her back down but
notice this it's so cool because you end
up having dr. strange who goes to bind
goo goes to bind Gamora and that's
basically the end of that and of course
she's she's basically tied up but then
she starts tapping in Morse code and
Captain America immediately picks up on
this and that's when he realizes that
they've basically switched it's actually
Carol Danvers who's laying on the ground
and it's Gamora who's who's essentially
you know appearing as Carol Danvers and
the reason why is because Gamora has the
reality stone this is one of the coolest
uses of the reality stone in Marvel
Comics history because you never really
see it used on like a small scale you
never really see someone distort reality
in such a way to make them appear to be
someone else and when Gamora realizes
that Captain America you know
understands what's going on she simply
says I really didn't want it to happen
this way all you had to do was play
along not ask any questions from there
Gamora single-handedly dismantled the
entirety of the Avengers team she takes
them apart piece by piece and this is
really kind of like a love letter to the
Gamora fan saying hey look she's just as
dangerous as you think she is even
though she's kind of you know falling
back to the wayside after the events of
like annihilation conquest even though
she hasn't really been relevant for was
essentially like 12 years he's really
been more of like a background character
a supporting character she still is
incredibly dangerous and she still is
incredibly capable in terms of her
abilities and it's cool to see because
you end up having Adam warlock whose
head is cut off because Gamora knows and
he'll just continually fight over and
over and over again Black Widow who
jumps in you end up having like Black
Panther who shows up and then she just
freezes time and she stops everything
and it sounds like everything is done
and then of course you know you end up
having Thanos
appears to her for a moment and so what
she does is she basically you know once
when she gets the sole stone from Adam
warlock she opens a portal to soul world
now again this is interesting here
because this is this is again Jerry
Dugan really hitting at the idea and
creating a story by simply saying that
Gomorrah wasn't really as free as she
thought as we thought she was
now again he's also shifting up the
nature of the soul stone in the sense
that what he seems to be doing here is
saying that unlike years past where you
had soul world inside the soul stone and
soul world was universal meaning
everybody saw the same thing they could
interact with each other it'd be like
walking around the city of New York
instead the interior of the soul stone
seems to be relative to the person who's
in it and so nobody can interact with
anybody else because they're in their
own their own individual version of soul
world and that's probably what you'll
end up seeing basically with with the
events of infinity war what you're gonna
end up having here is is what amounts to
like marble generations combined with
like the events of soul world and then
like the ribbon or the Nexus or whatever
it was with Star Trek generations that
terrible movie you're gonna have this
scenario where like you have all these
everybody who died in infinity war
they're gonna be in their own individual
soul world most likely and they may not
want to leave they may think it's like
you're actually an absolute reality so
again it's it's it's kind of cool and
it's kind of intriguing because it
leaves I'm almost lit on it you know
unlimited possibilities but when
gomorrah goes to merge with herself her
response is now I'm going to use the
Infinity stones I'm going to bring them
together and I'm gonna use them for a
singular purpose at which point loki
appears and says actually i have a much
much better idea on how these things can
be used effectively
but with that being said guys we're
gonna bring this video to an end if you
are new here to comments explained make
sure you guys at the sub button to
become part of the robb core if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and i will catch you all later
peace
[Music]
[Music]